يلا يا ولد نزل الشنطه
[موسيقى]
سعودي في واحد
روح قول له يقولك انا عمك انا عمه وتاج
راسي يوم الثلاثاء بكره الاربعاء ان شاء
الله عليك
انا احب الازرع البسمه امام الكاميرا
معروف انا بعفاوي عفويتي المسلسل مثل ما
قلت من اول حلقات مكسره الدنيا والناس
عبروا عن حبهم واشادوا بايداء او باداء
ابراهيم لدور ريان
مثل ما شفتوا كثار في التغريدات خلاص من
اول كم يوم حاسبين قراره ومش شايفين
ابراهيم الحجاج الافضل في الموسم الرمضاني
وعاجبهم المسلسل جدا وهنا لازم نقول ان
الفتره الماضيه كانت فتره انتعاشه
لابراهيم بدءا من جائزه
والان اصداء منه ولدنا اثنين واللي معظمها
ارشادات وثناء عليه خليه ينضم الينا من
الخبر النجم ابراهيم الحجاج اهلا فيك معنا
ابراهيم وكل عام وانت بالف خير يا رب
يعطيك العافيه شكرا استضافه انا ما عندي
طاوله هنا احط عليها يدي بس اني بقص يدي
كذا
حسيتك ابراهيم
اللي قلناها عنك
صراحه خجلتي تواضعي
[ضحك]
ابراهيم
اعتذر لك في العلن انا صراحه لما انت
تتذكر وقت لما ترشحت لي جائزه جوي قلت لك
ما في امل تفوز اه الجرح لسه موجود اوكي
قلت لك ما في امل تفوز لانه الاسماء اللي
كانت معاك كمان قويه جدا يعني الصراحه
فقلت لك ما في امل تفوز بعدين ما شاء الله
عليك فزت فانا اعتذر صراحه يعني ومبروك
الجائزه
جميله يعطيك العافيه اولا شكرا لكل كانوا
مناف صيني في جائزه جوي والبركه في الجميع
مبسوط اني فزت بفضل الله ثم الناس ثم
الفريق عمل ولدنا العظيم شكرا ساره انك
قدام الناس والان نستودعكم الله نشوفكم
كفايه
خليني احط لك الصوره بالله حقه الجائزه
لما نمت مع وحطيتها جنبك يعني في السرير
فيها حركه ميسي يعني من قد ما انت ما انت
مصدق انك انت فزت بالجائزه يعني حتى انت
كمان كنت شاكك يا ابراهيم
يعني هو مش زميل
ممكن تخاطر الافكار بيني وبينها بعد نفس
طيب
هنيئا له هنيئا لك بس من هو ولدنا الجزء
الاول
ما كان مخطط انه يكون في جزء ثاني صح بس
مع النجاح قررتوا انكم تعملوا جزء ثاني
والله الحمد لله يعني كان في
حوارات
اثناء عرض الجزء الاول مع الكاتب والمنتج
والمشرف العامل نحن نبدا نرتب جزء ثاني
والحمد لله هذا بفضل الله وبفضل الناس جدا
سعيد ان احنا جالسين
جالسين نعيش هذا العمل العظيم
مبسوط في بكل افراده احس اني بين عائلتي
والحمد لله ان شاء الله الجاي اجمل واجمل
والاحداث توها قاعد تسخن في العمل وان شاء
الله انها تنحرج مو تنحرق واو ساخنه فهمتي
لانه صراحه نحن في الجزء الاول قلنا يعني
كيف حيعملوا جزء ثاني الا رحتوا انتوا
قلبتوا الامور كلها وطلعتوا انه لا ممكن
تكون في قصه ثانيه هل نتوقع جزء ثالث
يا رب والله بالعكس من جدك وين حتروح
الجزء الثالث
مد
ري والله هذا كله عند كاتبنا العظيم فليح
استاذ خلف الحربي واذا استاذ عماد العنزي
واستاذ منير الزعبي المخرج يعني ان شاء
الله ما اعرف الحين خلي الجزء الثاني الى
عرض ان شاء الله ونشوف كيف قفلته الله
يكتب الخير يا رب بس انت متابع ردود
الافعال يعني
اي والله انها مثل الصدر ويا رب اكون قد
هالمسؤوليه وان شاء الله دائما يكون تحسن
الظن والله مشاعري يعني ماني عارف اعبرها
سعيد بكل شخص جالس يكتب تغريده جميله سعيد
بكل رده فعل جميل في مره فراشه وانا اسولف
من جمال الكلام والطاقه الايجابيه او انها
ناموس انا ما ركزت ما ادري بس ان شاء الله
خير ان شاء الله خير ابراهيم انا عندي في
مشهد في المسلسل اروع مشهد هذا بالنسبه
ليا خليني احطلك فهمني
خلينا
لحظه لحظه من فضلك
تعمل معاك لقاء وتتكلم عن قصه
خلاص قصتي قلتها كل الناس فاضي انت واي
احد يجي يقول لكم مقابله تدخلونا تحكم احد
كبير تركي العجمه
وتشريهان دخلوهم
طبعا انت قصدك كبير قدرا وقيمه
ايه طب انا والله صراحه كان مكتوب في النص
انا مجبورة يلتزم
يعني
وانت وانت اعظم مذيعه وكلنا نحبك ترى الله
يخليك تسلم انت منحاز ليا لانه احنا
اصدقاء فبتقول هذا الكلام باب الصداقه طبخ
طباختكم ادمان ترى
خلاص ابراهيم انا انا ما احب أكذب لا لا
خلاص طيب
ابراهيم بدي اكلمك كمان مو بس عن هذه
الاشياء بدي اكلمك عن ستار تجربه ستار
يعني انت ممكن انا عاصرت معاك قبل نزول
ستار كيف كانت عندك مشاعر خوف وترقب
والكلام هذا كله ردت الفعل او التعليقات
حقت الناس كيف شفتها لما نزل الفيلم
والله جدا يعني سعيد ان الحمد لله الى
اليوم في رمضان الفيلم لسه موجود في قاعات
السينما في جميع انحاء المملكه وايضا في
الدول الخليج جدا سعيد ان الفيلم لسه
جالسين نعرضه الى الان عليه اقبال جميل
الحمد لله احنا اليوم المركز الثالث في
تاريخ الافلام السعوديه والعالميه
والمحليه في ترتيب
شخصيا هذا اول فيلم طويل لي اول فيلم شباك
تذاكر شكرا الشميسي فيلمز ابراهيم خير
الله عبد الله العراك النجوم اللي في
الفيلم على
تلفاز 11 شكرا
قريب لقلبي وجميل انه يعني الان من ولدنا
جالسين يعرض وفي السينما ايضا ستار موجود
ما عندي مشاعر والله تشرح وش ودي بس انا
عندي امنيه ان احنا نسوي جزء ثاني من
العمل ان شاء الله
انت اشتغلت كثير على موضوع الملاكمه انت
اصلا تحب الملاكمه اصلا
مصارعه حره عفوا كله بالنسبه لي ضرب
كل هذا ايش هذا
لا تتمسخر
[موسيقى]
شهرين انا جلست اتمرن شهر ونص تقريبا مع
في دبليو منظمه السعوديه مهتمه بالمصارعه
عذبتهم اول اسبوع لان انا اسوي الحركه
واحسن اني انا سويتها بسرعه بس
يبدونيشن
في مخي الصراحه
طلقه
بس ان شاء الله يعني ان شاء الله
مصارعه ومشرف
واستمريت بعدها ابراهيم ولا خلاص رجعت
لاسلوب حياتك القديم لا يتضمن اي نوع من
انواع الرياضه
الا العب العب بلاي ستيشن شوي يعني كلمت
الشباب في سبيليو قالولي لا يعني مدري ليه
قالوا لك ملك
والله معاهم حق صراحه يعني افهمهم انا طيب
الفتره يعني احنا بنقول احنا ما شاء الله
2023 سنتك ما شاء الله ايش مخبي لنا في
الفتره الجايه
والله يا رب يعني يا رب انها من جد تكون
سنه خير علينا جميعا
في مشروع
فيلم جالسين ينطبخ على البطيء ويا رب ان
شاء الله انه يرى النور نهايه السنه مختلف
حيكون
لا لا ابدا
ابدا مالي فيها
ضحك بس
بدي اقول لك حاجه متى حنشوفك عريس ان شاء
الله لو حتصير عامل زي ريان مع فيروز في
المسلسل في من هو ولدنا
والله
[تصفيق]
في موضوع حساس شوي الله يكتب الخير يا رب
ان شاء الله توني صغيره انا ان شاء الله
اذا بعدين نتزوج يا رب ليه يعني توك صغير
يعني كم تبغى تتزوج عمرك كم يعني
[ضحك]
ايش فيك اوه
ان شاء الله يا رب دعواتك ادعي لنا ان شاء
الله الله يرزقنا الزواج قسمه ونصيب ايوه
لا انت ارتبكت بس احنا شايفينك بتعذب
فيروز في المسلسل فنشوف قد ايش الموضوع
هذا قريب من شخصيتك الحقيقيه
ظهر هذا تمثيل انا في الحقيقه رومانسي كفو
ونشمي كريم شاب يعني حلو وسيم من الجهتين
ابين وسيم
يعني طيب ابراهيم انا مره بتمنى لك
التوفيق دايما في كل شيء انت تعرف انه
يعني انت يعني صديق عزيز على قلبي يعني
وموهوب جدا الله يبارك فيك يا ساره والله
وانا اعزك وانت
اخت عجله الله يخليك ابراهيم انت من اول
هالكنا على انه عندك موعد عندك موعد تبي
تخلص ايش الموعد
والله عندي سحور
هذا كلها عشان تروح تاكل
طبعا انا مسؤول للسمبوسه اليوم
مقابله وشغل عن اعمالك وكده عشان تروح
السحور يعني ما اعرف ايش اقول بعد كذا
خلاص
شباب مهم طيب هذه اولويات الشباب شكرا لك
يا ابراهيم لا لسه بدري
شكرا
لك كان معنا ابراهيم الحج شكرا